[Musik]
mein Name ist Robert Lamprecht im
Zivilberuf arbeite ich bei einer
wirtschaftsprüfungskanzlei dort im
Bereich cybersicherheit im militärischen
habe ich den Dienstgrad mallor und
unterstütze des Bundesheer mit meinen
Kenntnissen und Expertise die ich aus
meinem beruflichen Leben mitgenommen
habe diese Erfahrungen die wir
mitbringen können natürlich sehr
vielfältig eingesetzt werden im Bereich
der ABC Abwehr wo wir
strahlenphysiker Chemiker unter gleichen
haben im Gesundheitsbereich die Ärzte
aber auch Juristen oder technische
Berufe man glaubt gar nicht wie
vielfältig die Möglichkeiten sind
dieses cyberfeld dürfen wir nicht
unterschätzen es ist zwar immer relativ
still und wir merken es nicht direkt
aber der Auswirkungen sind doch sehr
sehr unangenehm wir sehen die Bilder wo
ein Stau an der polnisch ukrainischen
Grenze war da Grenzübertritt war nicht
möglich weil die Systeme für die
Grenzabfertigung der Ukrainer
entsprechend gelöscht wurden durch
Angreifer
Ukraine kriegt man sicherlich zu einem
wachrütteln geführt das heißt das was
man vorher für unmöglich gehalten hat
ist von einem Tag auf den anderen mehr
oder weniger Realität geworden
inwieweit ich mich für einen Staat
einsetze ist natürlich auch eine
Haltungsfrage weil bin hier groß
geworden ich bin hier geboren ich darf
die Vorzüge dieses Staates und dieses
Landes genießen und wenn es wirklich
hart auf hart kommt muss ich auch die
Souveränität und meine eigene
Souveränität entsprechend verteidigen
[Musik]